PAMELA DAHER: In
October, Geo was
diagnosed with kidney cancer.
Chemo makes him very
tired, very sick.
ANDREA COLLITON: James
comes in and he's
able to work with our kids.
He provides them distraction
from their treatment
and to really help them
focus on something positive.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
JAMES ORRIGO: We came into
the hospital to work with Geo.
He did a great job explaining
some of his favorite things.
What's something
that makes you happy?
that makes you laugh?
We recorded that and sent that
over to the local high school.
We have, like, a
really special mission.
So what we're going
to need your help with
is to start drawing
and illustrating
the audio recording of
things that make Geo happy.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID BRITTAIN:
There are a number
of schools around the
world who use Concepts.
Our goal is to make it
simple and easy as possible
to express their ideas visually.
JAMES ORRIGO: And
what's even cooler
is that we have a whole music
department to create a film
score.
LAUREN HENDRY
PARSONS: We've created
a range of tools that empower
people to be able to make music
and having Chrome OS is a
really important part of that.
We've constantly used
the functionality
that Chrome gives us.
JAMES ORRIGO: One of the
coolest things that's happening
is Geo is actually
coming here today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
DAVID BRITTAIN: I never
imagined Concepts would be used
to cheer up kids in a hospital.
It pays back all of
those long, hard hours.
It's very moving.
LAUREN HENDRY PARSONS:
We should always
be thinking about how
what we're doing every day
is having a positive
impact on the world.
That's incredibly
humbling and inspiring.
PAMELA DAHER: We're lucky
that it is 90% curable.
Chemo is 31 weeks.
We're currently on week 20.
So we're almost at
the end of the tunnel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]